et là
C'est là
[Musique]
et là
C'est là
et aujourd'hui maintenant le président de la république
besoin de comprendre que les gens sont
marquer dans les moments les plus difficiles de
ton histoire des milliers de morts
familles endeuillées chômage un
le fantôme de la faim hante les maisons de
les habitants des favelas et à quoi s'attendre
un président de la république à l'époque
comme ça les pressions et l'espoir de
solidarité sobriété envers
ce que la régularisation foncière des
notre région c'est la raison pour laquelle c'est
et comment attendre au-delà de l'informatique
la manifestation ici aujourd'hui est pour le
les gens se souviennent de couvrir les autorités
position ferme et autoritaire qui
les autorités agissent comme un enfant
malheureusement, nous voulons que ceux-ci aient
comme l'autorité pour ces vies à
les plus pauvres n'ont plus besoin d'être creusés
des vies peuvent être préservées et
C'est là
et là
[Musique]
g1